the 5060. It's not the GPU we wanted,
but is it the one we needed? Kind of,
maybe. It's reasonably priced and offers
good performance for the cost. Doesn't
take too much power, so it's a great
card to upgrade most low-end PCs, and it
has plenty of stock. Sadly, no Founders
Edition, though. There was controversy
surrounding it when it first launched
due to only having 8 GB of RAM and
Nvidia releasing it just as most of the
tech community was on their way to
Computex and they didn't even provide
pre-release drivers. So, nobody was able
to even start testing and writing a
review until after the card was publicly
available. But now that we're just over
2 months after it came out, let's see
how everything shook out and how it
stacks up. The 5060 is the cheapest 50
series card that still uses GDDR7 RAM.
So, while it still uses a 128 bit memory
bus like the 4060, you get almost double
the bandwidth, going from 272 GB per
second to 448.
It has 25% or 768 more CUDA cores than
the 4060's 372 for a total of 3840. And
the boost clock didn't really change,
going from 2460 to 2497 MHz. However,
the base clock is another story. Going
from 1830 up to 2280 MHz. Tensor cores
and TMUs both got bumped up to 120 as
opposed to 96. And the 5060 kept the
same 48 rocks. Unfortunately, we don't
have a 4060 to test alongside it. But we
can compare it to the 5070. And since
it's in the same price range, we'll pit
it against the B580 from Intel as well.
So, for power draw, we're stating the
specs of the ones we tested. Just keep
in mind things can vary slightly
depending on what exact model you get.
Our 5060 has a 155 watt TDP and uses an
average of 106 watts. The 5070 has a TDP
of 250 and uses 210. And the B580 has a
190 watt TDP and used close to 165. The
low power draw also makes it perfect to
upgrade older systems as most power
supply should be able to handle it. And
unlike the small form factor ready 5070,
the 5060 has an actual lowprofile
version from Gigabyte. So whether you're
a true small form factor kind of guy or
trying to modernize an old mini PC, you
do still have an option for the current
generation. It isn't all good, though.
The biggest complaint there is for the
5060 is the only 8 GB of VRAM. So how
big of a deal is it? Less than it's made
out to be, but does have some effect.
The biggest issue is games like Indiana
Jones that take over 8 gigs at anything
above medium settings. Meaning although
the chip should be powerful enough, it
doesn't even get the chance to try. And
games like Monster Hunter Wilds or
Marvel Rivals will run at ultra settings
but would like more VRAM. So in that
case, you'll just experience a lot more
frames hanging and stuttering and a
overall worse experience. And based on
the low sales of the 5060, we can always
hope that gives Nvidia the kick needed
to actually produce the rumored 12 gig
version, but they're more likely to
rebrand your page file as AI generated
RAM before they squeeze a higher RAM
version in the $80 gap between this card
and the 8 gig 5060Ti. That being said,
if you were still considering buying a
B580 given its reasonable price and 12
GB of VRAM, it's hard to choose the
Intel card due to having less driver
support and more bugs in general. If you
can't afford anything over $300 and need
a GPU now, it's probably between this
5060 and a 960 XT, which we haven't been
able to review yet. And while you will
suffer forever with the knowledge you
bought an 8 gig card in 2025, you'll
also sleep easier knowing you didn't
give up real world gaming performance in
the process. And speaking of that
performance, let's get into it again.
We'll be looking at the 5060 against the
5070 and Intel's B580, both of which
have 12 GB of VRAM. The specific models
we have here are the Zotac AMP 5060 for
$320, the Founders Edition 5070 for
$550, and the Intel limited edition B580
for $250. So, let's start with synthetic
benchmarks, which we have 3D Mark Steel
Nomad with a score of 3,186 from the
5060. The 5070 got 5,149
and the B580 got 2,975.
And then we also have the steel nomad
light where the 5060 got 14,123,
the 5070 got 21,580
and the B580 got 11,91. And then we have
a side of pass mark with the 5060
getting an overall score of 10,574. The
5070 got 16,12 overall. And finally, the
B580 with 12,479.
On average, the 5060 beats the B580 by
about 6%. And the 5070 scored about 90%
better than the 5060, which all makes
sense, and the price of the cards
reflect this. But as for gaming, it's a
slightly different story. The 5060 is
first and foremost a 1080p card, but
surprisingly can also pull off some
1440. And just to simplify this, all of
the tests were done at ultra settings
with no upscaling. So that means there's
no DLSS4 trickiness where the 5060 is
generating three fake frames while the
B580 is living in the harsh cold reality
of rasterization. So let's look at
things like God of War Ragnarok. The
5060 got an average of 83 FPS at 1440
and 112 FPS in 1080. And in Hogwarts
Legacy it got 67 FPS at 1440 and 103 at
1080. Getting over 60 FPS at 1440p
though isn't the case for every game.
For example, Cyberpunk is running at a
still playable 41 FPS at that 1440p, but
a much better 75 fps at 1080p. The three
cards relative performance varies wildly
on a game-by-game basis, mainly between
the 5060 and the B580. Like in The
Witcher 3, where the 5060 gets 61 FPS at
1440, the B580 gets a whopping 101 FPS
for a 66% increase. Although it is worth
noting the B580 is much more
inconsistent, particularly when it comes
to the 0.1% lows, getting 83 and 29,
respectively, while the 5060 was way
better. However, in other games, for
instance, Black Ops 6 at 1440p, the B580
could only muster up 42 FPS, while the
5060 got 60 FPS for a win of 43%. And of
course, the 5070 is better than the
5060, but in this case, it only got 68
FPS, beating the 5060 by 13%. But now,
let's take a look at the multi-game
averages at 1080p. Just conglomerating
all the numbers together. The B580 comes
in at a 92 FPS average with 47 for the
1% and 24 for the.1% lows. The 5060 gets
an average of 101 FPS for a 10% gain and
53 FPS at the 1% and 43 for the.1% lows.
an 82% win on the 0.1% lows, meaning
you'll have a considerably smoother
experience. 0.1% lows just means that in
the lowest.1% of frames, that is what
the average FPS was at that. So, the
lower that number is, the more of a gap
there is between the average FPS and
what you're dipping down to. So, it's
just going like this all of the time on
the B580. And the 5070 got 138 FPS
average, which is 38% better than the
5060. and it had 751% and 55.1% lows.
And also, the 5060 is impressively power
efficient. For reference, as stated, the
B580 performed about 9% worse than the
5060 and took an average of 165 watts
while gaming and ran at 61° C. The 5060
only took 106 watts and ran at 51°. So,
you get 10% better performance out of
less than 2/3 of the energy, which is
frankly crazy. And even the 5070 is way
less efficient, taking almost twice the
power with 210 watts. And that only
gains you the 38% performance at 1080p.
Although performance does go up to 48%
increase over the 5060 at 1440, but
again, you're almost doubling the power
consumption. Now, as for how efficient
they are for your money at 1080p, the
B580 is still the best when it comes to
dollars per frame at $2.73
and stays the best deal as long as you
get it for under $290.
The 5060 is close behind at $318 in our
case, as our model is $320. But assuming
the $300 versions produce the roughly
same amount of frames, that would bring
it down to $2.98
per frame, making $275 the tipping point
between that and the B580. And the 5070
is a bit far off at $3.97
per frame, but it's hard to put into
perspective as we haven't tested its
more direct competitors. And for how
much hate the 5060 got at launch and
continues to get, there is one card that
it killed, the 3070. I know, I know a
lot of people have already written off
the half decade old card, but for
building on a budget, it has been a
fairly longstanding great deal. However,
with this 5060 launching at the same
roughly $300 mark that it took to get a
refurbished 3070, it's time to send it
off into the sunset. For their
performance, they trade blows in most
games. The 5060 is slightly behind, only
by a couple frames, though, with the
1080 averages being 102 FPS for the 5060
and 103 for the 3070. funnily enough,
from a VRAM standpoint, they're almost
identical. While the 5060 has GDDR7
instead of six, the 3070 does have
double the bus width, so they end up
having the exact same 448 GB per second
bandwidth. The power draw, on the other
hand, couldn't be more different. As
previously stated, the 5060 uses about
106 watts while gaming, and the 3070
uses almost twice that with 190 watts.
So, with having the same price and
performance, with the 5060 taking half
the power and being brand new, so you
don't have to deal with eBay or worry
about the car dying from old age, and
you want a warranty, the 5060 is the
clear winner between those two. So,
while the 5060 was launched in an
utterly terrible fashion, it offers
solid 1080p performance at a pretty good
price and can even squeeze its way into
some 1440p gaming. And while the 8 gigs
of VRAM are less than ideal, it only
poses an issue every once in a while.
And you can easily work around it by
just lowering the settings a little.
Again, all of our testing was done at
ultra settings, which is going to
consume as much VRAM as possible. You
can definitely lower it down to get
better frame rate, which is what you're
going to have to do to get a good amount
of frames in demanding games. And if
you're making a budget Nvidia build,
this has crushed any reason to get a
3070. And even outside of Nvidia, I'd
probably still choose the 5060 over a
B580 because it's barely, if at all,
more expensive, gets better performance,
and gives you a way smoother experience
overall. Even if the dollar per frame
goes in the B580s favor, the gaming
experience on the 5060 is something that
is harder to tell with that dollar per
frame chart. But I can already forread
the comments asking about the 960 XT.
Don't worry, we just got those delivered
this week and we'll be working to get a
review out on these ASAP. I had it
backwards and we'll make sure to compare
it directly to the 5060. I just need you
to sit tight for a moment longer. And if
you want to see the PC that we'll be
building the 9060 into, you can come sit
tight and watch our Twitch stream and
also enter in for a chance to win an
RTX5090 gaming PC.